the south of France is famous for its
very special light and light of a
different sort is an important business
here this designer lamp costs five
thousand euros guess you know that this
is a very flat Oh LED light apricorn are
the largest in the world so we've held
the record for that for three years ask
the machines can't produce larger ones
than that at the moment no cafetto
Chaudhary only limited palette idea
that's why we're still limited you just
can't produce larger ones yet he's a
certain all-round OLEDs are the standard
design produced here at ostrom fiamma
into law the o LED lamps are made by
hand and they come with the made in
France label often associated with
luxury goods but they also include
technology developed in germany the
company founder takes us to see the
nerve center at the heart of this
franco-german project the clean room
this is where the oleds are manufactured
a chemical vapor coating is applied to
glass or plastic the materials come from
Germany supplied by a strim pm's partner
company no valid the Germans supply the
materials exactly as they're needed I
make no valid we work with our partner
Nova led on various molecules working
out what the dosage needs to be how many
nanometers of which molecules need to be
led on top of each other to manufacture
a certain o le D this bottle came from
Germany last week this alone cost twenty
thousand euros and this is where it came
from the city of Dresden in eastern
Germany The Dresden based company Nova
LED is a huge laboratory employing 120
people
yeah that's the spirit invisible the
head of the laboratory is French
although he speaks excellent German it's
truly a joint french and german project
am Rana thought he'll joined Nova led
five years ago epoch legitimate this
when I was writing my PhD there weren't
many jobs available in France all the
important companies in this area would
employ people with a doctorate in
chemistry were in Germany so I came here
here in Dresden OLEDs are only produced
for test purposes in order to see how
well the chemicals function work on
organic light-emitting diodes is still
continuing their lifespan in particular
is still too short but they have huge
potential a smooth one day OLEDs will
line up our world in a completely
different way they could be stuck to the
windows for example in the day they'd be
transparent at night they'd light up
folks sec cases good these are the kinds
of things we're working on particularly
with white light but we want to
revolutionize lighting back in France 30
employees are busy making large-scale
lights designed for palaces railway
stations or major stores the
franco-german project has been going
since 2007 some duplicates we're too
small companies and we both have our own
cultures the development of the
chemicals in Germany and the production
of the lamps and elegant luxury lamps
here in France and we've managed to
bring these two different cultures
together a video three different on solo
and the two companies serve many
distinguished customers this lamp needs
to be perfect it's for the French
interior minister